welcome back so we're talking about data
science in this intro to data science
lecture series and I said in the past
that data science is largely about
asking and answering questions with data
so kind of the cycle of asking questions
and then trying to answer them with data
data-driven inquiry is is one way I like
to say it and I really want to dive into
what are the types of questions just
some of the like flavor of questions we
might ask with with data a lot of data
science kind of culminates in machine
learning where you build a model that
you can then deploy and use in the
future you can run hypotheses through it
you can run forecasting and scenarios
and you can use it in the field for
example to classify images or you train
a robot and you want it to go and be
autonomous and do something so so you a
lot of data science is culminating in
machine learning and models that you
will use in the future after training
them on data and so a major question
that I ask all the time in in data
science is does the past and so data
often is from the past does the past
represent the future and this can be
kind of that's a fairly vague statement
but I think you get what I mean
I have historical data often I've
collected a bunch of data can it
represent the future how can I use my
data to predict the future those are the
kinds of questions so does the data I've
collected do it does it have any bearing
on how I want to use my models in the
future the decisions I'm going to make
in the future at some point that asks
the begs the question what do I want a
model I have to - what do I want to
model it's not a beautiful sentence so I
have to ask myself what can I model what
would be useful to model
what do I want to model in the future so
in some cases it's pretty clear-cut
you know Facebook wants to be able to
take a picture of a face and tell who it
is
you know in an image search and Google
if there's a picture of a cat it would
love to be able to label what's in the
image or even what the image what's seen
it represents some cases is a little bit
less less obvious what you want to do so
you know what do I want to model in a
you know fluid flow well that requires
me to ask to do some hypothesis testing
of what I can model what would be
interesting but you always ask yourself
what do you want to model and a more
kind of we're just drilling down in
specifics here so does the past
represent the future what kinds of
things do I want a model how will the
model be used that's critically
important how will the model be used
who's going to use the model how is it
going to be used is it gonna have to be
very very fast is it gonna have to be
flexible and working scenarios that the
training data didn't didn't see you know
is it gonna have to generalize is it
who's gonna use the model is this model
gonna be used you know for something
that societally criticals it's going to
be used for you know the judicial system
and sentencing people based on
information because then you better be
able to explain the decisions you made
and things like that so how will the
model be used is safety critical is this
for an autonomous vehicle a self-driving
car okay so you have to know kind of
does the data I have represent the
future how what do I want to model who's
going to use the model on how and then
at this point it's critical to ask what
data do I need right so this is data
driven at some point so what data do I
need and a similar question is what data
do I have do I
it okay so what data do I need what they
did do I have
okay so we're asking questions about
what data we need and then you have to
ask how hard is it to get the data okay
and so this is just one kind of stream
of questions that you might be asking
that eventually culminate in kind of
data so now I have identified the
problem I want to model who's gonna use
it and how what data I'm going to need
so that the past will be useful in the
future
I know roughly how I'm gonna get the
data or at least I have an idea and then
I collect that data and I start trying
to build models and answer those
questions and so what I've pointed out
to you is kind of this path here where
the questions are somehow motivating the
data that I'm gonna collect so you know
sometimes someone just hands you data
and you mine it and see what you can get
out of it but really if you can be part
of the question asking the problem
solving procedure and again this is why
you want teams that have you know
problem-solving experts in data science
experts and you want your problem
solvers to know some data science and
your data scientists to know some
problem-solving because if you have the
ability to you know have this this pipe
line of questioning culminating in what
data to collect and how you're going to
store it and analyze it this tends to go
a lot better than if someone just hands
you data and says what's in it okay but
then you start analyzing the data and
what you might realize is that your
question wasn't the right question in
the first place
so if if you're lucky this will motivate
kind of a refinement of your questions
maybe maybe you decide that there's
something different you can model or
that you you can't model what you
thought maybe there's just not the
information in the data that you thought
there would be but that motivates a
different set of questioning a different
use case and so this is kind of a
feedback process and at multiple levels
you want this to feedback between
questions and data okay so for me that's
really the essence of
data science is asking and answering
questions with data all right thank you